that's the great weeding out that's
happening this is the Great Purge the
Great Purge that's happening is if
you're going to be a matrix zombie or if
you are going and then eventually get
killed because AI robots and all that
is taking over anyway or if you're
going to Homestead and build the new
basic needs infrastructures of the world
and say you to all of that
those that come on this ride are on the
Warfield they're living their truest
because they know that this is the only
way forward there's no more sitting back
back and doing nothing that it's not
going to work anymore there's a certain
time during the spiritual journey where
it makes sense to learn how to do
nothing and feel the Divine silence and
Stillness underneath of everything but
that's a short part of the journey
that's a short part of grocking what one
truly is because then that must be
integrated into the body into the war
field itself and go and fight
and die for the new world